a journalist in New York City home of
Brooklyn and people write for BuzzFeed
and he joins us tonight Chadwick I know
I'm painting with a broad brush here but
I can kind of picture the staffer in
question sneering at the middle of the
country and maligning an entire group
based on their skin color which I
thought was not allowed right yeah I
don't leave your guest for one second
when he thinks you're former guests when
he says he thinks that these these
articles are meant to be satire make fun
of racism no no no it's exactly I think
how you painted it these sort of liberal
Oberlin kids who graduated and live in
Brooklyn and and for some reason and
want to believe in this sort of
dismantle the wealth narrative and they
think the way to do that is to attack
white people I mean it's it's Marxism
it's socialism and it has the mainstream
media's ear it has mainstream societies
here when you see these people who
obsess over victimhood so much it's so
fascinating because if you want to see
racism everywhere if you're brainwashed
to see racism everywhere or homophobia
everywhere or whatever then you will
that's the world you were living you
know I was having a conversation with
with the woman not too long ago about
this a young upper-middle class black
woman and she was talking about how
badly she you know gets treated on the
street here in New York and I said to
her what if you lived for one day as a
white woman and you were treated the
exact same way people were just as rude
to you what then yeah it's doesn't make
anybody happier to see everything
through that lens so let me ask you
about something that happened yesterday
on the view I personally missed it but
I've seen the tape maybe you saw a
Cohoes Joy Behar reacts as the ongoing
protests we've been seeing in Iran by
saying the u.s. is on the very brink of
executing gay people in the streets
watch this it's not apples and apples
it's not equal but we're on a very
slippery slope slope in this country
toward throwing democracy out the window
every single we have to defend the
freedom of the press and civil rights
here we do pedantry for being gay yeah
yeah now how close do you think we are
to a country where people are stoned in
the streets for being gay is Joy Behar
suggests look you know I have to tell
people this all the time we can't even
get funding for the wall so the gay
death camps are definitely not happening
till this
second term I mean we really have some
time to paddle this she's she's
completely ridiculous this narrative
that they want to push is so absurd
there's no proof to it it's total it's
just at such a load of bull I don't know
in that same discussion she was sort of
ironically saying that the protesters in
Iran and the the so-called women's
marchers here these resist protesters
she called them protesters are basically
fighting for the same thing and she said
well you know the details are different
about what what they're fighting against
but the the general thing that they want
democracy and freedom and ours is deeply
under attack in this country all right
well firstly let's talk about that in a
rant and you have women tearing off
their head scarves and Ameri jobs and
here in New York and in Washington you
have women and men liberal men putting
them on as a symbol of liberation and
when she says yeah it's so funny to see
her saying our democracy is under attack
but it's also I mean it's such grotesque
overstatement and I know what it's like
to get mad on television but part of
your brain says you'll pull back a
little bit you know don't say more than
you mean don't overstate things for
testily because if you do you're gonna
be called on it and you shouldn't say
things that aren't true no one ever
calls anybody on the left when they say
the gluta Chris things like gays are
about to be stoned in the streets what
yeah yeah exactly it's it's just this
hysteria and they they have no evidence
for it they have absolutely no evidence
for and it's it's exactly they're just
showing you they are they have no
arguments childish yeah it's very sad
much more great to see you all right
Thank You Tucker